i actually think that
part of the reason that peter jackson's
original three lord of the rings trilogy
turned out so well
was because he made it in new zealand
far away from the distractions of
why do popular franchises fail
i feel that popular franchises tend to
fail because
corporations are incapable
of making them under the current
factory filmmaking conditions
one
popular franchises
are
created
generally by a singular person
who
was not paid by a company to think that
up that it was an idea that came
not necessarily fully formed but
percolated for years from that person's
experiences whether it's a gene
roddenberry with star trek whether it's
a george lucas with star wars whether
it's a j.r.r tolkien
with the lord of the rings series
a franchise comes birthed
from a person not because a company
hired them to think up a new franchise
it came out of someone because it was a
creative thing that they needed to
express
and
big companies which are required
to fully fund a huge property or
franchise uh
the conditions under which
content is made at those corporations
is not conducive to a singular creative
voice
it's
art by committee
there are other concerns budget is a
concern
is it gonna have a happy meal
i mean um tim burton famously uh got in
trouble
after the uh sequel to his 1989 batman
film starring michael keaton the second
movie batman returns was much darker in
tone and more to tim burton's creative
liking
and it
infuriated mcdonald's
because
here was a movie that was kind of
frightening to young children
they even mcdonald's even issued an
apology there are videos on youtube you
can look up about this
mcdonald's actually issued an apology
when they released a series of penguin
catwoman and batman toys because the
movie didn't really fit the young
demographic that would have bought say a
happy meal
uh so you've got
your your
your budget concerns
your are we going to be able to make
toys are we going to be able to you know
put the cast in that we want like
in addition to concerns about well
this movie costs a lot is it going to
play in other countries
is it going to play to a worldwide
audience because we're spending
400 million dollars on this thing
once you have all of these concerns on
the shoulders of a creator it's very
difficult
it's very difficult to come out the
other end with something that
still has that vibrancy of a single
creative vision now some filmmakers have
learned to work within that system very
well
i would say that uh christopher nolan is
one of the filmmakers that has
had more success than failure in in that
working within that system
although they've been uh you know i
don't know if there was a happy meal
necessarily for the dark knight batman
movie i don't remember actually i should
know that um
but his other films as well in addition
someone like a denis villeneuve with uh
dune he was able to
balance the studio concerns and
have a vision that was his vision of the
novel uh frank herbert's original novel
for dune
so
it can be done but i do think that it
requires
a singular creative visionary that has
the full support of the studio when they
say look
when chris nolan says we're not going to
do inception toys
maybe listen to chris nolan that like
hey this movie i don't think the toys
are necessarily
going to work with this
right so
but when i think
once you have
you know signed over the rights to
whatever it is star trek star wars a
lord of the rings
and handed it over to a group of people
who never created it to begin with
then what you've got is you've got that
new creative team now saying
i'm going to do my version of this
when it's something that maybe george
lucas would never have allowed to have
happened
or a gene roddenberry would have said
that doesn't fit the universe where
tolkien would have said no this is not
what would have happened in this
universe they're not there to be the
checks and balances so when you've lost
that primary creative voice and it just
becomes a piece of ip
you know when it's looked on as
intellectual property and then you've
even got in that mix the concerns of
stockholders now for the company like
well
you know we're just going to do this
because it will appease the stockholders
you have so many concerns it's a miracle
that almost anything worth watching
comes out of a studio these days
so
i think that's where they go wrong is
you've lost the original person who is
the shepherd for the franchise whether
they're actually directly doing the
writing or not right
so you've when you've lost that shepherd
and it goes to a corporation i don't
think a corporation is the best fit
for
the
most positive result
it can happen and it does happen there
are glimpses
but
for the most part i think the era that
era is gone
i don't think we'll ever see like a
george lucas or gene roddenberry or or
someone like that ever again
the hoops that you have to jump through
the concerns that you have to balance
stockholders toys budget this
you know
it's it's amazing i think that's a skill
unto itself now i would love to hear
and i've had very frank and honest
discussions with friends of mine in the
indie film world who all say you know
it's almost like a lot of these movies
the story behind the scenes of making
the movie turns out better that's a more
interesting story than the movie because
the fact that okay we got the financing
but
the girlfriend of the main investor
who's putting in 10 million dollars she
needs to be the lead and she's not that
great
and
so you're juggling i can even i can
almost tell when i see a small indie
mover i'm like oh these are the
compromises that person had to make
because these are the weakest parts of
the movie
and the filmmaker is just fingers
crossed hoping you don't notice
so
um it's almost as if uh i i think a lot
of filmmakers
would benefit from you know
taking some courses in therapy
in diplomacy
and
in finance
in addition to being
decent at making films in order to be
able to set those concerns aside and and
make something creatively fulfilling and
worthwhile with that singular vision but
i see franchises you know going off the
rails and i'm like
it's just too many cooks
it's
it's corporate content too many cooks
made by
you know committee
you you can just see it
you know this recent um teaser
for the lord of the rings
the rings of power just came out
and there's a 56 second trailer for it
and i'm looking at it and to me
it looks like a powerpoint presentation
that was shown to amazon to sell the
series
i don't know what connection it has to
lord of the rings to me it looks like
dollar store game of thrones i it
doesn't have the feeling of the lord of
the rings it's a miracle that peter
jackson
was able to make lord of the rings with
um with his own creative vision but
being incredibly respectful of the
source material and that's a thing that
i think is not spoken about enough the
respect for the source material
and i know that peter jackson he's even
spoken about this you can look up
interviews with peter jackson he said
you know i have my own personal ideas
but these aren't my ideas this is
tolkien's story i'm going to tell his
story and this will be
you know his own vision of that and i
think that uh
i actually think that
part of the reason that peter jackson's
original three lord of the rings trilogy
turned out so well
was because he made it in new zealand
far away from the distractions
of
that could have consumed him
from
you know the the corporate overlords in
in in hollywood so so
being off making those movies uh
away from that distraction in in new
zealand i think actually helped quite a
bit